is that a conflicting view that we are
resources to be optimized is that is
that somehow
deeply conflicting with the fact that
there is a ground that we stand on
absolutely so what heidegger thinks is
that this is this he calls this the
supreme danger of the technological age
is that without ever having chosen it
without ever having decided it this is
the way we understand what it is to be
us
but he thinks that um it's also he says
quoting holderlin this 18th century
german poet he says in
in the supreme danger lies the saving
possibility so what does that mean it
means that we this is the this is the
understanding that we've been thrown
into that we've been given it's the gift
that was given to us
it's supremely dangerous if we let
ourselves live that way
we'll destroy ourselves
but it's also the saving possibility
because
if we recognize that we never chose that
that
it was given to us
but also we were implicated in its being
given and we could find a way to
supersede it
that it's the ground but it's also
updatable he calls the ground the
groundless ground
it's it's not like an entity which is
there solid stable
like god
eternal and non-changing is always
updating itself and we're always
involved in it's being updated but we're
only involved in it in the right way if
we listen
like miles davis
you